>> Mark: LOOKING AT THE CLIPPERS
BENCH.
GETTING A FOUL FOR TALKING TO
THE CLIPPERS BENCH.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO WAIT FOR SUBS
TO COME IN.
HE WANTED A KNOCKOUT PUNCH.
>> Mark: NO.
HE WANTED THAT TECHNICAL.
>> Mike: DeMARCUS COUSINS WITH
SOME WORDS.
NOT ONLY THEY NOT PLAYED THE
PLAYOFFS THE LAST TEN YEARS BUT
ZERO PLAYOFF APPEAR ANS FOR THE
SUNS AND ONE WINNING SEASON AND
THEY HAD SOME BRUTAL SEASONS
WINNING 19 GAMES, 21 GAMES, 23
GAMES.
LAST YEAR, THEY WILL TURNED IT
AROUND A BIT.
COFFEY MISSES THE TECHNICAL FREE
THROW.
YOU CAN SEE TALENT WAS CHANGING
AND ADDED JAE CROWDER AND CHRIS
PAUL BUT IT'S NOT OVER YET.
BOTH COACHES EMPTYING THE
BENCHES.
SO MUCH EMOTION FOR CHRIS PA
NBA FINALS.
>> Mark: AS CLASSIC A GUY WILL
YOU FIND.
MONTY WILLIAMS WENT AND VISITED
HIM PRIOR TO HIS DEATH.
A CLASS ACT AND A WONDERFUL MAN.
>> Mike: WHAT AN IMPRESSIVE
PERFORMANCE HERE IN THE
CLENCHER.
CHRIS PAUL BACK-TO-BACK ROUNDS
WITH BRILLIANT PERFORMANCES.
AGAIN, HE HAD 37 IN THE CLENCHER
AGAINST DENVER AND 41 HERE IN
THE CONFERENCE FINALS.
SESTOS WERE THE SUNS
TOO MUCH TO OVERCOME.
CARTER KNOCKS DOWN THE SHOT.
WHAT A TURNAROUND OFFENSIVELY
AFTER STRUGGLING LAST COUPLE OF
GAMES AGAINST AN EXCELLENT
CLIPPERS DEFENSE.
THEY EXPLODE FOR 130 POINTS.
56% SHOOTING FROM THE FIELD.
OTURU'S SHOT WON'T GO.
A WHISTLE.
A FOUL.
THEY WILL WILL HOME COURT
MAKES HIS FIRST FINALS BY
BEATING THE TEAM THAT HE PLAYED
FOR SIX YEARS.
A TEAM THAT WAS PART OF A LOT OF
HEART IN SPORTS.
>> Jeff: THE BEST THING SCOTT
SAW WAS CHRIS PAUL'S SECOND
HALF.
>> Mike: HE'S HAD HIS SHARE OF
HEART BREAKING PLAYOFF LOSSES
BUT A TIME TO CELEBRATE AS HE
WILL GO TO HIS FIRST NBA FINALS.
WILLIE GREEN, FORMER NBA PLAYER,
AN ASSISTANT COACH.
BACKCOURT VIOLATION.
THE CLIPPERS WILL JUST DRIBBLE
IT OUT.
ANOTHER BIG ROAD WIN FOR THIS
TEAM.
THEY HAVE HAD SO MANY OF THEM.
GAME FOUR AGAINST THE LAKERS.
GAMES THREE AND FOUR AGAINST
DENVER.
NOW GAMES FOUR AND SIX HERE
AGAINST THE CLIPPERS IN THE
CONFERENCE FINALS.
WESTERN CONFERENCE FINALS ARE
DONE.
PHOENIX SUNS, FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN 28 YEARS, ARE GOING BACK TO
THE NBA FINALS.
THOSE TWO COACHES, MARK, YOU
WERE RIGHT.
THEY DID MAGNIFICENT WORK.
TWO GREAT YOUNG BASKETBALL
MINDS.
SUCH RESPECT AND ADMIRATION FOR
EACH OTHER.
A ROUGH ENDING FOR PAUL GEORGE
AND THE CLIPPERS.
SPECTACULAR PERFORMANCES
TONIGHT.
YOU WOULD LOVE TO SEE THIS
RESPECT AT THE END OF A VERY
HARD-FOUGHT PLAYOFF SERIES.
>> Mark: YOU LOOK TY LUE A
FORMER PLAYER AND CHAUNCEY
BILLUPS, A FORMER PLAYER.
THEY UNDERSTAND CHRIS PAUL'S
MARCH TO TRY TO GET TO THE NBA
FINALS AND BE A CHAMPION.
YOU KNOW HOW HARD THAT IS?
THEY ARE ACKNOWLEDGING HIS
GREATNESS AND HIS PURSUIT.
>> Mike: THEY LOSE ONLY FOUR
GAMES.
THERE IS MARK BRYANT, THE
ASSISTANT WHO HAS DONE WONDERS
WITH DeANDRE AYTON.
ONLY LOST THREE IN THE FINALS.
6-2 ON THE ROAD AND THEY ARE
YOUR 2021 WESTERN CONFERENCE
CHAMPIONS.
>> Mark: I WANT TO SAY THIS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT SAY CHRIS
PAUL IS NOT A WINNER BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP.
CHRIS PAUL GETTING A PHOENIX
SUNS TEAM TO THE NBA FINALS TO
ME IS MORE IMPRESSIVE THAN SOME
TEAMS THAT HAVE WON A
CHAMPIONSHIP.
YOU KNOW HOW INCREDIBLE A